juste avant c'est ma petite récréation
de la semaine sur 4
j'ai une question pour vous vous la
voulez dites moi est atone et ça marche
pas mal et ça veut dire qu'est ce que tu
dois aller on dit que tu sois bonjour je
m'appelle liliane j'aime beaucoup la
variété mais en deux ans des missions je
n'ai toujours pas vu un chanteur que je
connaissais se produire sur votre
plateau comptez-vous bientôt faire un
live donné un à moose cory comprendre la
déception cher liam est a priori non
c'est pas prévu de live de nana
mouskouri la programmation musicale de
tp est très précise du rap du rap
vincent nick lowe du rap c'est oublis
sont empressés ça l'est si vous rentrez
pas dans une de ces catégories c'est
compliqué et ça interroge beaucoup les
chroniqueurs la semaine dernière je vais
montrer matthieu delormeau peu réceptifs
au look de niño et rim cap en live ça
vous avez n'avait d'ailleurs jamais
parce que j'ai moi c'est vraiment c'est
je suis fan absolu et ben là je vais pas
vous mentir quand l'artiste est venu sur
le plateau et son petit sac à dos à son
bord à l'exploratrice
ça n'a pas arrangé les affaires oui mais
pour mathieu cécé pas c'est pas assez
payet ça
bonsoir à tous
glory
tout avait quinze filles
[Musique]
m
les locaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
/
après tout
après toi je n'ai rien dit
on va dire
après l'allemagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est écrit sur les murs voilà ça et que
c'était mieux avant le chanteur avait
des looks de l'encens de couteau s'était
bien battu qui est pourtant bien content
d'aller voir les rapports à la pub pour
regarder des vidéos pour les réseaux
sociaux genre je connais des stars ça c
est la spécialité de mathieu là vous
allez voir il va les voir dos et pour
discuter enfin surtout il va parler tout
seul comme d'habitude ce qui le plus
mignon c'est jean pierre descombes qui
juste après le départ de mathieu va
vouloir faire par ailleurs
des carlingues
thouars jean-pierre n'attend que
l'accord est l'amour mais c'est le mois
jean-pierre c'est d'abord lui mais je
voulais dit il ya dedans tp il n'y a pas
que du rap est aussi dû au goût sting et
yoda ou assimilé cette semaine on a vu
le vrai hein mais la semaine dernière
logo ci ngaliema de la semaine c'était
un verre au soler j'adore à vous le plus
grand plaisir de jean michel
[Musique]
salerno
[Applaudissements]
ce maillot des champions
je suis très très fan de toi qui
longtemps
oui mais jeannette est mignon aussi je
suis vert à l'excellent oui mais bon
c'est une star internationale
je ne vais pas laisser son titre sophie
ah bah oui sophy vous êtes au claquage à
des papes et tous les jours par
l'espagnol c'est vrai c'est le succès
assuré il ya des époques comme ça
maintenant vous faites un espagnol
[Applaudissements]
et
alors il faut savoir que les
chroniqueurs font leur marché parmi les
invités comme mathieu 1
enfin surtout mathieu battu vous allez
voir c'est faisable si vous êtes invités
et que vous lui plaisez vous pouvez même
avoir une danse privée
je sais que toutes les meufs sont comme
des folles aussi sur l'île parce que pas
que trop quand ça marche du temps au
temps du vol quand tu faisais toile
voir le docteur
à
j 1
pégase de leurs mots de bourgogne pour
quoi que dise à mathieu m'avait dit
qu'il était sur le dos mais rien à voir
stéphane pas du tout il n'est pas du
tout sûr d'autres mais mathieu il est un
petit peu sur tous les deux chez tous
les dossiers sur le dos de stéphane il a
la dalle quand même mieux en ce moment
stéphane lui a fait comprendre que ce
n'était pas son délire voilà allez on
passe au top j'ai danse cette
compilation des moments qui peuvent se
passer que dans tpm
[Musique]
non
daniel est bonne aujourd'hui
vous daniel aujourd'hui
effrayé
parfois tu nous lis
[Musique]
non
et
le premier ministre et mme annie michaud
construit dans fort boyard les avale
vous êtes éliminés du monde ici mais
catherine ici on se sont passées à son
père bah oui bah donc passer cet
mais qu'il est trop si c'est son père
c'est qu'il a le même nom de famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on put à la pâte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime
[Musique]
bonjour à la fin pour les vendeuses
mathieu vient des jolies femmes tu as un
long couteau tu es une fille nahla
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous ont la même série comme ce que tu
dis citons qu'elle serait pas que même
temps qu'elle aime faire et d'en faire
centre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le happening qui tourne mal maintenant
car y en a toujours un la semaine
dernière on avait pensé que ça serait le
happening [ __ ] à mouches les
chroniqueurs étaient déguisés en bouche
chez jean pierre descombes leur taper
dessus on l'a toujours pas complet il y
avait évidemment c'est le happening
tango qui a posé problème c'est pas si
vous vous souvenez rats sont nico devait
noter les duos de danse des chroniqueurs
oui j'aurais pas dû un conseil pour nos
futurs invités
si vous donnez une note à benjamin
castaldi donné aux hommes car après
c'est lui qui sera si tous les missions
à côté de vous les combats jara n'est
pas content ces mots dépassent sa pensée
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
durand
je suis parent absent du côté des plus
belles voix de la chanson en français
mon ami pardon excusez moi c'est mon ami
en plus vraiment débat il chante pas
très bien
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire une
chose pareille je fais vraiment vu
parfois il avec c'est bon j'ai fait moi
si on me signale qu'on doit pas laisser
l'antenne quelques instants place à
l'actualité il s'est passé des choses
incroyables
benjamin castaldi aurait eu une
conversation intéressante avec jean
pierre descombes
tout ça bien sûr à taponnat fadi sionnel
ça concernerait cyril hanouna a
non parce que c'est pas je suis au début
du mois savais pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore dette mais encore il pas là
uniquement
merci bon rien d'un peu plus sous mais
quand même à bien sûr bien sûr mouchet
et on commence par cyril qui une fois
n'est pas coutume à avait juste envie de
dire un truc gentil à matthieu delormeau
arrive très souvent
excuse moi tu es bon franchement dès
qu'on met des mots d'amour mais mortel
quand je vous vois la vérité elles ont
pris un coup les trois drôles de dames
et le poids hapsatou sy j'ai eu accès au
téléphone longuement et j'ai eu la
chaîne au téléphone je vous dirai tout
vous êtes téléphone m
matthieu delormeau remettra en jeu son
titre de cadors du post
ne comptera pas qu'on s'énerve et les
[Rires]
affaires des commandes avec mes
chaussures mais je me plairait dans un
instant les cherry ou alors on le croit
pas comme une villa sur des biens par
l'histoire du dégât si tu fais des
drones toit d'un bus toutes les infos ou
encore l'émission me suis dit qu'est ce
que je peux faire vraiment pour me
détendre et là chez les mecs
ni une ni deux je me suis fait tous les
replays des chiffres et des lettres
cet automne c'est mon premier succès
dans un grand jeu télévisuel témoin vous
cachez pas là
[Musique]
ennahda est la règle
ça
la russie va pas finir non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas compris la
métaphore est en tout cas et je vous le
dis et mathieu tu es formidable
franchement mine de rien eu
d'exceptionnel pour jonathan
cette année je suis fou de lui et vous
relaver dernier voulait bien le ton très
dense il a cette année encore plus c'est
à dire que je ne peux dire est que je ne
peux pas m'en passer
bonjour luc merci pas acheter dragueur 6
6 % ht de raquette par contre vous non
mais lui c'est à dire il n'omet pas une
dedans ça nous fait vraiment bahri ben
je plains votre compagne à les frères
mince et tous les chroniqueurs toutes
les équipes pour bosser comme agent pour
cette émission
[Applaudissements]